[Musique]
je vous retrouverai
oui ce sont les trois derniers mots que
je vous ai dit
mais
la vie et la fin du monde
[Applaudissements]
en ont décidé autrement
ravi de te rencontrer Guess
vous êtes au courant de ce qui se passe
dehors
c'est la guerre
nous combattons notre extinction et nous
sommes en train de perdre
jusqu'à aujourd'hui il s'est servi d'un
de nos enfants pour faire ça
l'antidote il nécessite entre autres
un ingrédient non conventionnelle j'ai
pas peur de toi
ils ont besoin de nous on va les libérer
l'eau il nous reste plus beaucoup de
temps
on peut tous être le prochain
tu es prête je suis prête comme jamais
[Musique]
tu auras beaucoup rire aussi vite et
aussi loin que tu pourras tu ne seras
jamais en sécurité nulle part
promet moi de finir le job
[Musique]
et j'ai bien l'intention de l'admire
croyez-moi
tout type est peut-être notre seul
espoir
[Musique]